Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 8th,
2014.
How are Ya?
How's it gone?
Oh,
I bought that bag up.
Boot it up.
Put it up two weeks in a row.
Fuck you.
I'm excited.
I told you last week how excited I was about the NFL football season starting.
You know,
and I'm kind of sucked for me because I missed all of it.
Basically I was flying back from Toronto.
Um,
I went up there for the Toronto International Film Festival of Rational National
Fossil Hall up there in Toronto.
Um,
cause I got a movie a,
I don't have a movie.
I have a partner movie.
Take the ego down a little bit.
Do you really have a movie?
What do you have build?
You have a home movie that you shot about you rubbing your balls in your bed.
All right,
relax.
I have a part in a movie called black and white starring Kevin Costa and Octavia
directed by Mike.
Um,
I really want to see somebody from Boston talking about this movie when it's
coming out.
Somebody at a lower level who hasn't taken a speech class,
career speeches,
what they call it,
you know,
when you get into mainstream media,
good evening,
welcome to the nightly dues.
And you can't tell where the person's from.
No accent.
So basically everybody can understand you slash they're not laughing at the way
you speak.
You know,
I want to see the local person in Boston doing this new movie coming out,
black and whites starring Kevin Costner,
Octavia Spencer directed by Mike binder.
Come on down to MVP sports.
We got all the jerseys,
we got the shacks to steal.
Is the charges in more.
Um,
anyways,
that's actual copy for a long time ago from an MTV,
MTV MVP sports radio spot.
We've got the shacks,
the steel is the charges and more,
more.
Do you really have more?
You don't have less now we got more um,
Jay Mohr.
Anyways.
Um,
yeah,
so I was on the plane.
I missed,
I missed all the games.
Uh,
miss my patriots getting their asses and the second half evidently by the Miami
Dolphins.
And,
um,
I want to Wa I wish I maybe the NFL network where we show some of it.
I want to watch it.
I want to see what happened.
Um,
I was actually on the plane coming back,
Flying Air Canada and I'm thinking,
all right,
well,
well let me take you through the whole thing.
I flew up,
uh,
was it Friday night?
I mean the lovely Nia,
we flew up there for the film festival and,
um,
I shot this movie last year.
Remember last year when I told you I was in New Orleans,
for those of you who are listening last year,
um,
yeah,
you know,
we shot this movie and I lucked out because it was hot as balls.
Um,
the level of humidity was something I had never experienced other than when I
was in New York City.
And I remember late night standing on a subway platform on the ground.
And basically,
I mean,
it was already hot as fuck outside and then underground.
You basically with this air that was trapped after the sun had been beating on
the asphalt above,
heating up all the air underneath for 24 fucking hours,
whatever the hell it was,
and was just standing there like a fucking Zombie in the late night if he never
lived,
you know,
in a city,
the trains don't run like every six,
seven minutes.
If you miss a train,
you're going to be there for an ungodly,
like 20,
25 minutes.
And usually what you thinking is this,
please don't let anybody crawl up from the tracks and you know,
drag,
you know,
four or five of them grabbed me by the legs and pull me under to their
underworld cities and use me as a food source.
That's what you usually worried about or getting stabbed or getting robbed or
whatever.
Um,
on that particular night,
none of that entered into my mind.
I was just standing there.
Um,
I remember early on before I got delusional Iros wondering why,
what if I,
I should probably not stand too close to the track because if I get so
dehydrated and pass out and fall onto the tracks,
I'm going to get run over.
Um,
it was just brutal.
So what,
anyways,
I had not experienced seat like that.
Is that any ways down in New Orleans since my days living in New York City and,
um,
I really lucked out if you go and see the film,
which I hope you do,
it did really well,
uh,
at the festival.
And um,
I remembered,
I just totally lucked out where all of my scenes were indoors.
I only had one scene where I had to get out of a car and just walk up to a
Kevin's character's house.
But other than that,
I was inside the whole fucking time.
Even when I was outside,
I was inside,
I was to be sitting in a car and we'd be cranking the AC and then shut it off
right before they did the take a completely fucking lucked out.
But anyways,
so,
um,
went up there for the premiere and,
uh,
it was a,
it was an awesome time.
Got to see everybody in the cast.
It's an unreal cast.
Anthony Mackey's in it.
Um,
I play a lot.
I play a lawyer and,
uh,
I'm representing Kevin Costner and Anthony Mackie represents Octavia Spencer's
family and,
uh,
you know,
it was pretty insane.
It was definitely one of those,
how the hell did I end up here moments,
what am I doing here and how soon am I going to get fired?
You know,
one of those deals.
And fortunately,
none of that happened and I had a great time,
but,
uh,
so it was,
it's been a year since I've seen everybody in the cast or whatever,
so we all got to hang out.
Um,
got to watch the film front of a crowd,
which is fucking nerve racking.
But fortunately they got on early,
they got on the ride early and they just,
you know,
yeah.
And,
uh,
went great.
It went great and I had a great time and went to the after parties,
did all of that type of stuff.
Blahblahblahblahblah blue and all that.
You know,
funny when we went to the premiere it was hilarious.
Was there,
they bring you over there,
right?
And it's this huge film festival.
I come from the stand up world so I have no idea.
So um,
there's all these big time movie actors there.
So anyways,
when they bring you over to do the red carpet,
um,
they drive you over and like you know,
whatever the fuck we were at all we went to a dinner now there was an early,
that's right.
There was an early yeah,
thank you all meet up and then they do the press junkets tells well work
the is little boy was it excited to work with little buddy look this good but
boob they do all that.
Yeah.
Shit.
And you just put on your happy face.
Oh my God.
It was amazing.
Everybody was so amazing.
You just do that shit.
You go into that mode,
right?
So then they bring us over,
Did you pulling up to the red carpet and there's fucking probably eight,
nine people deep
wrapped around this semicircle where all the cars are pulling up.
Cause they want to see all these big time fucking Hollywood stars.
So Lo and behold,
one of the first ones to come down the fucking path was me.
Right.
I wish I don't,
I,
I've never done one of those.
I wish I fucking videoed the looks on people's faces.
The fucking manic look of excitement past we'll cut combined with where is the
famous guy.
So they are looking,
looking into the truck and they're like,
Eh,
and they're looking at me and then quickly look,
cause I just,
you know,
I'm standing there,
I'm going a suit.
I look like a fucking agent.
They don't know the fuck I am.
So I,
the door opens and the crowds like as I go to out and immediately it just
fucking,
you know,
like the beginning of a football game where everybody's going crazy and you get
ready for the,
for them to kick off and the,
and the kicker starts running at the ball and then the wind blows it off the tee
and then the crowd has to die down before they start going,
ugh.
That's basically what it was.
Me Stepping out of that truck was like the football falling off the tape and uh,
I,
yeah,
I was,
they weren't,
they were looking at Neil like she was in the movie.
They thought she was in the movie.
They were like,
who is that?
Was is that,
you know,
fucking
okay
is that will Smith.
Um,
anyways,
so then whatever went out and did the red carpet,
red carpet was the same experience,
which was fucking hilarious.
Was people talking to me asking me questions as they were looking down the
carpet to see,
you know,
where the real person was that was coming.
So I just started making joke.
Everyone I went as whenever they would look,
I'd be like,
yeah,
don't worry.
Kevin's common Kevin's coming.
You wrap it up with me,
wrap it up.
And they'd be like,
oh no,
no,
no.
It's like,
yes,
yes.
I get it.
Him,
you're waiting for him.
You know,
are,
you're not going to use this.
So,
um,
I had a great time.
It was making me laugh the whole fucking way down cause I just kept addressing
that.
And,
um,
it was just,
it was a great time.
And,
uh,
you know,
okay.
I don't know.
The whole thing was,
it was interesting going through there and they just,
some of the questions that they would ask who kind of like open ended,
they'd be like,
you know,
this movie deals with race and in the light of the call and Ferguson's little
flu,
it's like this thing was made a year ago.
This was made before then.
What do you feel,
uh,
how do you feel that this movie is good to a thick,
the boob?
But what am I a fucking source or,
I don't know.
I think people are gonna think what they think.
All right,
Bill.
Thank you very much,
Ken.
Okay.
So anyways,
uh,
I got to do all of that shit and um,
it was definitely a good time.
And,
uh,
we saw the movie movie did great and uh,
the crowd really seemed to like it,
blah,
blah.
And we went to the after party.
Um,
and that was a really interesting thing too,
because I didn't understand what was going on.
We went to this party and we're sitting at a table and it was who I thought were
these random people at the table.
I'm like,
who are these fucking people sitting here?
Why am I,
what am I talking?
And it turned out these were the people that put,
you know,
a lot of the money up for the movie.
So basically for you,
when you guys do your movie,
all right,
and you go to the premiere and you step out and you get to experience what it
feels like to be the human version of a football fallen off a tee.
Um,
afterwards you go,
I guess the next party you go to is people that put up,
you know,
I know Kevin put up a bunch of money for the movie and then there was like a,
I dunno,
these other people that put up money for the movie.
So they then have a dinner and then you go when you interact with them and
basically thank them for putting the money up for the movie.
Old fucking freckles didn't realize that I'm looking at this guy,
is it okay for doing?
Who the fuck is this guy?
Um,
and then once I realized,
I was like,
Oh wow,
okay,
okay.
Oh,
we're still playing the game.
I thought the game was over,
you know,
it was halftime.
I thought once we,
once we did the whole fucking premiere of it and it went well,
I thought that that was the end of the bullshit and that old Billy could start
drinking.
So,
um,
I gotta be honest with you,
I didn't really drink that that night.
That,
that was one of those nights you don't drink.
You know,
you just have to be kind of on point the entire time.
But it was,
uh,
it was definitely a lot of fun.
Unfortunately Not Toronto is one of my favorite fucking cities.
I just like going up to Canada,
man.
I really enjoy it.
And uh,
but you know,
I was only up there for like 24 hours,
so I didn't get to do some of the things I got to do when I did the tour with
fuzzy.
Um,
but definitely stayed at the same hotel.
My favorite hotel up there at a fucking steam room.
Some old man,
shit,
I gotta be honest to you with steams are the best fucking thing ever,
you know.
But anyone with time you smoke a fucking cigar.
I swear to God,
you taste it the next day until about two in the afternoon.
Unless you wake up in the morning,
Bu Du,
Du,
Du and you go take a steam,
you take a and you just sweat out all the impurities and I'm telling you,
that shit comes right out.
You're fine,
you're fine.
You're sweating out all the cancer.
Um,
anyways,
so that's the deal.
So that movie comes out,
I believe end of October,
early November,
I'm definitely going to get a Mike binder,
the director who put me in the fucking movie,
literally.
Um,
I'm going to definitely going to get him on the podcast at some point and
possibly,
maybe another cast member will stick.
We will definitely see.
So please look out for that.
Please go pay to see the movie.
Please don't steal it.
But you know,
at the end of the day,
you have all the power.
Um,
all right,
let's continue on.
So anyways,
so then,
then,
uh,
I,
what did I do?
Okay.
So then the next day I wake up,
I take a steam,
right.
And I go over to the fucking airport,
let me mail Billy fancy pants,
right.
Taking steams,
going to premiers.
I had a big weekend.
I'm not gonna apologize for it.
Took me 22 years.
Um,
so,
uh,
I went over to the airport and I'm sitting in the,
I'm sitting at the airport and they have all this NFL pregame going on and I'm
thinking,
fuck,
I'm going to miss everything.
And I'm watching the pregame and which I never watch and I haven't really
watched it in years.
It's why I don't know anybody's names any more.
And I'm really bad at that.
I mean,
part of it's cause I'm on the road all the fucking time,
but,
uh,
I think,
um,
I dunno,
sorry guys.
Can you tell them looking at something else here on the computer?
I,
so I'm sitting there watching it and uh,
the first thing I see and I started tweeting this shit and it kind of started,
I got a little thing going on Twitter.
I'm just the dumb shit that they say in the whole fucking um,
the NFL pregame
helix freezer tape right there.
Okay.
Will you see right there?
What are you each making decision?
He is making decisions and that is a good thing he's looking at is not only you
last year he was just looking,
it was his first week.
He was telegraphing where he was going to throw the ball and if she right here
what he's doing,
he has no checking down the field.
It chicken in third read.
No,
I can tell you when a quarterback judge did daddy's,
when he's doing to play the quarterback position in the field level,
right.
Fucking all of that shit.
Just a bunch of fucking people in suits.
Okay.
Breaking down the game the way it never needed to be broken down.
It is completely a product of fucking 9,000,
24 hour sports channels.
I mean,
dude,
I'm sitting there.
It's like two and a half hours.
Yeah,
before kickoff and they're already doing pregame.
It's like dude,
pregame used to be a half hour before Brent Musburger,
Irv Cross,
that Kennedy woman,
whatever the hell.
Jackie can't not Jackie Kennedy.
What the hell was her name?
Um,
and then Jimmy,
the Greek that was CBS and then NBC.
You had fucking Bryant Gumbel and Mike Academy.
NFL 81 right?
That's what the fuck do you do?
That's all.
You just watch that and they went around the league and it was cool.
Bing Bang,
boom.
And you were done and then you went to your local fee.
Now you just got,
these guys are out there.
They're acting it out on that half a football field
over and far.
Tell you right now we're trying to do is you're trying to turn around the
culture in the locker were in the locker room for years.
It is.
It has been a mentality that we are not going to win the big one.
And that's why they brought in Joe fucking bag of donuts,
combing their great playground but stupidest shit ever
over it fucking over and over.
So anyway,
so I go,
I get on the,
I started tweeting all of that shit and uh,
you know,
just make an a player names and all the dumb shit that they sell.
Yeah,
he's a changed man.
He came in,
he came into camp in the best shape of his football life.
Okay.
It's with the,
to his coaches yet his wife and he,
oh,
he tested positive to weed and I'll tell you that type attitude,
that type attitude is contagious and the locker room.
Okay,
how many fucking time did they even sit there?
Rolling their eyes with their,
if their football speak drives me up the fucking wall.
How anyway,
she,
what he needs to do is he needs to feel the pass rush you have in the national
football league,
which you have to be able to do is feel when that pocket is collapsing around
you.
But you got to have a clock in your head.
You got to have a clock in your head and you don't want,
once it's clicking down,
you have to know.
You must get rid of the football cause I'll tell you right now if you don't do
that and you take a sack right there that,
that,
that is a drive killer,
Mike.
Okay.
Oh absolutely.
Absolutely.
I fully agree what he's doing here.
He goes,
you go.
He's parodying the ball.
He's telegraphing is Paris is,
this is the type of stuff that they worked on in the off season.
He showed some promising moments in the preseason,
but I go to tell you today,
I don't know where that was.
I got him up here.
I got to wonder,
is it time you hit the panic button?
Darby chat,
Bruh.
Who the fuck can sit there and watch that horse and then what I love is sports
fans.
Okay,
watch that shit and then it gets,
it's like a virus and then it gets in their fucking heads and then they go out
to sports bars and you talk about football and then they start sounding like
those people.
No try.
You know George,
you got to have a fucking clock in your head,
kid.
One,
1002,
1000 fucking get rid of it.
Throw it out of bounds.
Joe,
you're allowed to do that.
As long as you're within the confines.
You the fucking pocket.
Dude.
I can't,
I can't fucking,
I can't go to sports bars.
Why would you?
I don't give a fuck how fucking broke you are.
There was no reason to not have the NFL package.
Dare is it all right?
You can go 40 fucking days without food as long as you got water,
you fine.
Do yourself a fucking favor.
Starve yourself and yes.
Okay.
I'm advocating Anorexia to get the NFL package to not go down
to the fucking sports bar.
Eating that heart attack food.
Yeah,
watch it.
A bunch of grown men walking around and jerseys like the dating,
dating the fucking player.
Don't all day.
Well
Dan,
Horse Shit.
You gotta go down there looking at those tired waitresses join a horror it up
and they're fucking cutoff ref shirt
listening to that bullshit.
Unbelievers.
It tied to make a change.
I'll tell you,
I made it up.
I bought,
I am.
If I am the offsets of coordinator who's head you got to understand with this
kid,
this kid is Chad 19 offensive coordinators and the last seven seasons.
Okay.
I still don't think that we have,
see what this kid is able to do up there.
I'm still holding on.
Yeah,
you could.
You have to learn your skin.
Did he hit her head?
Achy hinge?
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't fuck.
Right,
right,
right.
I'm annoying myself just,
just even listening to this shit.
So anyway,
so I get on the fucking plane and all I want to do is watch the game and uh,
you know,
it's funny to watch a fucking game on a plane.
I've been able to,
it's just,
it's the best.
It's just fucking blows through the whole flight mean three hours.
I mean,
you just crushed your flight.
And,
uh,
so I get on there,
you know,
and somebody always has money on it or somebody is like totally ended the team,
you know.
You know what's funny is if the game kind of boring and then you turn it right
and then all of a sudden some happens and here's these guys,
like whatever,
like 10 rows back.
And I'm like,
whoa.
Any quickly turn it back on.
Um,
you start watching it.
It's the best time of the year to fly.
Provided you're on like a virgin or a jet blue or somebody like that that's
going to American Airlines where they're going to have the fucking game.
Uh,
unfortunately I was on Air Canada.
We don't give a fuck up by Yo,
Eh,
do you ever American sports?
You know what they had?
I saw sports in my heart is pumping,
going,
oh my God,
I'm going to have NFL football.
All right,
I'm going to be flying over.
What's the closest NFL city to Toronto.
Okay.
Is it Cleveland or is it Detroit?
Both the separated by water.
Right?
What gave am I going to get?
Am I going to get Pittsburgh?
Fucking Cleveland did Detroit play?
I don't even fucking know.
I missed everything.
Um,
I get to get the Chicago game.
Hey,
maybe I'll get lucky and I'll get to watch my patriots play the Miami Dolphins.
Right.
Okay.
So I click on the sports little thing there and unfortunately I got uh,
all they had was taped games games that already happened and it was highlights
from the 2014 World Cup.
So
I did what any man does in those moments.
I can't watch sports.
I'm going to watch a documentary cause that's the only other thing that's going
to fucking be engaging
enough.
Um,
oh fuck.
22 minutes and I got,
I got to read some advertising here.
Hang on a second.
Hang on,
hang on,
hang on.
Um,
alright.
Oh,
speaking of football,
everybody,
fantasy football players.
I got something here for you.
All right.
If you just want to stop talking trash to your friends,
you actually want to make a little bit of doubt.
We got the draft kings,
the draft kings,
everybody sounds like a Doo wop group.
Um,
fantasy football's back and draft kings.com is not messing around.
Draft kings.com is America's favorite one week fantasy football site where you
could win a enormous cash prizes every single week.
You've already researched the players for your season long fantasy team.
Turn that knowledge into instant cash at where?
Draft kings.com last year,
one player turned 11 bucks into four grand in one weekend and I'm like,
I'm calling this right now.
This website is going to be huge.
Um,
another one,
a hundred grand,
his first time ever playing and another player won a million bucks in one day.
Just playing fantasy football.
Keep your season long league where it is,
but also play one week fantasy@draftkings.com to win huge cash is twins.
Huge cash this weekend.
Hurry,
get free entry into a millionaire.
What a maker event where first place takes home 1 million bucks.
Head over to draft kings.com now and enter Promo code defense,
d e f e n s e to play a free to become a millionaire.
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger wing and winner winning's bigger millionaires stem and I almost got
through it and your defense for free.
Entry now@draftkings.com draftkings.com that's draft kings.com um,
do that website is going to be huge.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody ever wonder why razors are so expensive?
I mean,
does it make any sense?
Big Shave companies are changing,
are charging you for ridiculous shaving technology.
You don't need first vibrating handles.
Then flashlights.
Now pivot ball,
flex heads.
What's going to happen next?
MP,
three players.
What else do we need in there?
You know,
enough is enough.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com.com for a few bucks a month.
They'll shave.com delivers the world's best razors right to your front door.
Not only are they cheaper,
they bring them right to you.
This is the greatest idea ever.
I think dollar shave club dot coms are better than the big shape companies for a
fraction of the price is so easy.
Go to dollar shave club.com pickup one of their raises.
They start at three bucks a month.
You don't have to break the bank.
You don't have to get your care.
You don't have to resort to cheap disposable razors to save cast all
shape.co.com is amazing.
Every month they ship you automatic deliveries.
You'll never forget to buy blades again.
You don't have to squeeze a squeeze shaves out of a dull,
dirty old razor blade.
All right?
This is a joke.
This is a no brainer.
You get to shave with a fresh blade every week.
This is absolutely mandatory for anyone that wants a great shape.
He deserve better than a dull blade,
you know,
and you have a finite time on the planet earth.
Why wasted standing in line at CVS?
No more ridiculous shaving technology.
Make the smarter choice.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bird B u r r that's dollar shave club.com/bar are
right back to the podcast.
So anyways,
so I get on the fucking plane and I click on and all they have is highlights of
the World Cup.
And I'm thinking,
all right,
I deserve that karmically.
I've done enough piece of shit things in life.
I deserve the fact that NFL football is not on right now.
And I have to watch World Cup repeats of World Cup soccer,
which I would watch if there was an NFL football on the real football,
not the football.
The rest of the world plays,
you know what the rest of the world is there,
like a bunch of mainstream fucking hacks.
You know,
they all want the same football,
right?
Like that fucking teeny bop and whore,
whatever the fuck her name is Miley Cyrus,
like if she fucking played a sport,
she plays soccer.
American football.
That's like the underground band with balls that's trying to stick it to the
man,
man.
Sorry.
Whatever.
I like football.
Go fuck
yourselves.
All right with your fucking bangers and mash.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
The fuck am I talking about?
So I get on this.
So yeah.
So I,
I'm like,
what am I going to watch it?
So I started watching this documentary about this dolphin that was hanging out
around New Zealand and this woman started hanging out with the dolphin,
started thinking about the dolphin in the middle of the night,
if it was lonely.
And she go in the water with the thing that we've got really fucking creepy.
You know when people start fucking befriending a wild animal,
especially when it lives in a fucking a world that you can't breathe and you
know,
I guess it's a mammal.
So it comes to the surface.
Is that the connection?
I was like,
wow,
you have to come up for air too.
So she started getting really creepy close with this dolphin and then they
started showing the fishermen that were getting annoyed by the dolphin cause it
was eating all the fish.
And it was getting right to that point where I'm like,
something tragic is going to happen to this doll and I'm going to start welling
up tearing up on an airplane and I don't want this to happen.
So I turned the channel.
That's how I watch all nature shows.
I watched the part about the animal and right when it gets to the point and then
man came and they show that fucking machine that just pulls trees out of the
ground like the hulk.
You ever seen that fucking thing where one man in this God damn machine could do
more fucking damage than a fucking hurricane,
you know?
So I kinda knew I was going to tap out.
So I tapped out on that and I decided to watch some classic TV.
And um,
this made me feel really old in classic TV.
They actually had wk RP and Cincinnati.
And I remember when that show came out.
I used to watch it every week.
You guys remember that show?
No.
Well,
here's a little reminder,
but dupont do,
baby,
if you ever wondered,
maybe this is a freshman member,
uh,
your memory,
Wanda,
whatever became of me,
I'm living only,
hey,
we're in Cincinnati,
Cincinnati,
w.
K.
O.
P.
Remember that bill?
There's no way you're going to sing the whole song.
Got Tan at Saddleback back in town to town,
a bed down the die.
Maybe you were me were never meant to be just baby.
Think of me once in a while.
I'm met.
Damion,
you
p.
So I watched an episode of that and I got to tell you,
I don't think I've ever seen a writer's room just tap out the way they did at
the end of that episode.
Okay.
It was just fucking episode where Dr Johnny Fever,
they have basically given away $5,000 like 100 bucks at a time throughout the
summer.
And Johnny fever reads it wrong and says it's a $5,000 giveaway.
So they go,
fuck,
what are we going to do it?
Mr. Carlson who runs the,
the station goes,
if we have to give away five grand,
not only his favor losing his job for some reason.
Uh
Okay.
Andy Travis is also going to lose his job as well as Venus fly trap.
Who's another fucking DJ?
But I guess they threw him in because he was African American.
But fuck you.
We've been looking for a reason to get rid of you anyways because this is
Cincinnati in 1979.
Okay,
so what do they do?
They guide you,
basically you got a name five songs only here in a couple of notes.
So they splice them together so fucking quickly they don't think anybody's going
to get get it.
But of course somebody gets it and now they got five grand of cash.
Everybody's going to lose their fucking money.
And then what ends up happening is this guy shows up,
the claim,
the money they give the guy the money and he leaves.
And then two seconds later the real guy shows up and they realize they gave away
the wrong money.
But Johnny fevers smelled a rat and he went down and he got the money back and
hands it to Mr. Carlson and that evidently made,
made it all better.
And then they ended the episode.
It's like a,
wait a minute.
What about the guy who actually want it?
He's standing there and you still got to give him the five grand
and then it just ended.
Okay,
they played the ends.
The ends off bad data.
Bob made a
damn about [inaudible] Pat,
I'm not even exaggerating.
That's how the song goes at the end of Wk Rp,
you can't understand one fucking word.
Hey Hannah,
Hannah where Gig Buddha
and then the cat comes up
and that was seventies fucking television.
Sorry.
Anyways,
um,
so let's get to my fucking,
my New England patriots.
I didn't see anything of the game.
I just saw the highlights.
But uh,
I got to admit,
I can't say dude,
I called it,
I can't remember if I said it on this podcast.
I sent it to a friend of mine where I thought this year the Patriots were going
to dip a little bit and everybody else in our division was going to get a little
bit better.
It's just a,
okay.
It's just what it is.
It is what it is.
You can only be on top for so fucking long.
We've been on top of our division anyways for a long fucking time.
And um,
I don't know.
I Dunno.
It just seemed like we were actually doing okay against the team.
Was it like 20 to 10 or something like that at the half?
And then we just,
we couldn't do anything after that.
They went,
are they married her half time?
A judge Birch and then the Patriots never judged you to you time
to tell you,
you know.
Oh,
I,
for one I didn't like their tray.
Logan,
could you go juggle jokes?
You boy.
Okay.
I'm sure that doing all of that shit.
And everybody freaking the fuck out about where the Patriots are.
Okay.
First of all,
it's only one week and then second of all,
you know,
not for nothing.
We're on a 14 season run.
I think we've won the division every fucking year.
It saved me except maybe once or twice throughout Tom's whole career.
I think the jets one at one year.
MMM.
No,
they couldn't want it to do then when that year,
because we never played them in a way game,
they always came up to,
to meet.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
all I remember the year a Brady went down and we went 11 and five and we didn't
make the fucking playoffs.
I think when we had Matt Cassel.
And that was when Paul Versey said,
Matt Castles for Real,
the guy's for real.
These mobile in the pocket will blow all that type of shit.
And I was like,
dude,
he's fucking,
he went 11 and five with the 16 and o team last year in the regular season.
He lost five more games than the team did.
It's the fact that you're counting down from 16 and now it's 11.
If they won 12 the year before.
All right.
Do the fucking math.
I had to say that to give myself a chance to catch up,
they would all,
they would have gone seven and nine.
Right.
But I say five less five less from 12.
Yes,
seven and nine.
Then you would have been like,
this guy stinks.
Ship 'em out of fucking town.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I would say that Logan Mankins was,
I mean obviously that was a main,
a main point,
but it also sounded like they,
they are,
once again,
our fucking defense is another issue.
And uh,
I dunno,
man,
I,
I didn't see the game,
but it sounded like,
you know,
we've got Vince Wilfork back and it just sounded like they just kind of went
through a defense like butter.
Uh,
so we will see what happened.
I'm by no means conceding the whole fucking year because of one week.
But,
um,
you gotta be honest,
like as a sports fan,
how long can the Patriots keep winning division,
the AFC east and how long can the bills Jetson,
dolphins suck mean you suck every year.
You gotta be drafted really high,
right?
At some point you got to pick somebody.
I don't even know the name of the Dolphin's quarterback,
but I kind of looked up his stats from last year,
the gamma's through for 4,000 yards.
The Guy,
he's no slouch.
Oh,
Joe.
You know,
these teams,
they know each other.
They meet twice a year.
These teams,
they know what they do.
And Antonio Toyota,
I know it's hard to be team two times one season.
MMM.
So it's going to be really interesting to see.
Uh,
I don't know.
I'm a fucking nerd,
man.
I,
I still love the shit.
Even,
even if we suck this year,
I'm still gonna Watch every game and the less,
you know,
I'm on a Goddamn airplane,
but,
uh,
you know,
it what it is.
You can
only fucking hang in there for so goddamn long.
Not to mention bill Bellacheck has been the guy,
so everybody dissects.
What the fuck it is you do.
They take your coaching staff and every,
the fact that he's been able to go on the run that he's been able to go on this
is fucking amazing.
And also how excited people were when they saw Tom with his head down,
you know,
and the towel over his head,
like he had fucking congestion or something like that.
Right.
Could just did,
knows failure,
whatever the fuck it is.
Um,
that actually made me laugh.
Like people,
like best picture of Tom Brady ever.
All that says to me is a patriots fan is this guy's been raping you for fucking
the better part of a decade and a half.
All right.
Um,
so we shall see.
We'll shit,
we'll see what's going on.
I missed everything.
I missed college football.
I missed absolutely fucking everything.
I don't even know what happened,
so I'm just going to shut up about it.
Um,
and with that,
let me get into,
uh,
some of the reads this week,
for the month of loading park.
They didn't do anything else.
I'm trying to think.
Oh,
you know what I was watching last night.
You don't,
I'm fucking car crazy right now.
And I watched this great,
uh,
this great youtube video of,
um,
the fucking Mercedes Benz,
SLS AMG GT,
right?
That one that opens up like the original one from 1955 with the goings.
And,
uh,
it's a base price of 221,000,
$580.
And you know,
those are the kinds of cars that you look at.
I was looking at the roadster,
by the way,
which I guess is 228,000,
$80.
These are the kinds of cars that you look at when you go on the fucking
Internet.
It's great cause back in the day you would,
you would actually have to go down to the lot if they even had one and they
would chase you away.
They'd see you walking up going,
Oda,
forget that.
Hey,
your fucking bomb.
We got chevettes down this street.
They're freckles.
So what I love about this thing is you can actually walk,
like I watched a whole test drive.
This guy drove it through.
Um,
you know,
we started off on the coast of Portland and road,
drove it all the way up to mount hood.
And what was funny is a lot of the roads he was on,
or at least the areas he was on,
I've actually been,
I've actually driven on but probably in like a fucking a Chevy Lumina or a dodge
neon or of,
what else did I always fucking end up getting somehow.
Okay.
Ford Taurus,
if I a splurge for the full size car.
I used to do this Gig,
this college down in Coos Bay on the coast of Portland.
And uh,
I used to drive down cause I was trying to save money and uh,
I used to always do it.
I would,
you know,
I'd have a Gig on the fucking western part of Nebraska and I would fly into
Lincoln and then just get on the 80.
I still remember the highways,
the 80,
the 80 was all the way across Nebraska.
The 70,
that was a
Kansas.
Then when you got up north it was 90 and 94 and that went through like,
okay,
the Dakotas and Wyoming and Montana.
Then nuts.
Okay.
And I think it's the 40 is south of the 70.
For those of you haven't done a lot of road shit.
Uh,
even numbers go east West on the interstates in,
in odds go north,
south,
let some truck and shit for you.
All right.
It starts out on the west coast.
Okay.
Pacific coast highway.
Let me see how much this is my OCD kicking in the you got,
what does that do?
That's for one,
but they got a route one on fucking east coast to whatever.
You got the five.
Okay.
Right.
That goes from San Diego all the way up to the fucking Canadian border.
Then you got the 15 and I believe the 15 that goes off of the 10 it goes all the
way up to Vegas,
continues up through Utah.
Then you can make a right at the 70 and take that all the way to New York.
I've done that.
But if you continue on up,
which I've never done,
that goes right up that splits fucking Nevada and half and I think it goes up to
Boise,
Idaho or into Montana or some shit.
Then you got the 25 which is basically starts in breaking bad country.
Okay.
Goes right up through Denver,
Cheyenne,
Wyoming,
all the way up to fuck in the middle of why a fucking Montana.
Then you've got the 35 I took that one,
drove that one up from Austin,
Texas up to Dallas.
That one goes right up to fucking Oklahoma,
right through fucking loa up then.
I don't know where it goes from there.
I never did.
The honor was 65 or something.
You can take that from Indianapolis down to Nashville or something like that.
It's some 60 something.
I used to do that all the time and I was trying to sell tickets down south.
I do Bob and Tom and uh,
I dunno.
And then all the fucking rest of them,
95 and all those kinds of,
sorry.
Anyways,
so I'm watching this fucking video and I used to do this gig down there in Coos
Bay and uh,
so this guy's driving this,
but you got to see this fucking car dude.
It's a fucking God damn James Bond car.
Uh,
it's unbelievable.
Okay.
I was actually looking at it going,
you know what if I sold my house and I just put it all into that car,
um,
you got to hear the thing.
It's just fucking insane.
I am completely sold on German cars.
I just think they're the fucking best.
Um,
I do like Italian cars too,
but you know,
the Germans,
they just take it to that next level and it,
it really is because they don't care.
They just don't care about human life.
You know what I mean?
They don't,
and I know that you say,
well,
what about all this safety?
I,
they doing that for their area and brothers,
they're doing that to protect the fear.
That's
why they,
they,
they make the car is safe as it is,
but it's not for guys like me.
Like,
you know,
if Hitler,
if Hitler like succeeded.
Okay.
And he exterminated all the people he wanted to exterminate.
How long would a fucking redhead like me be able to be able to stand in his
vicinity before onto,
I'm sick of looking at that gets a writ.
I never would have fucking made it.
Um,
anyways,
they'd throw me in right after the fucking albinos.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
there their cars are just fucking insane.
And uh,
I am still 100% hooked on that.
Uh,
I think the fucking Mercedes Benz stationwagon AMG is one of the coolest fucking
cars out there just as far as a sleeper.
I just think that is the sickest car.
I got a couple of videos.
I,
I'll,
I'll send you a link of the video for,
um,
for that,
that,
that um,
that Mercedes SLS,
gt roadster that this guy took.
It was just,
it just was the fucking shit.
You know what I mean?
Oh my God.
Why did I look at that fucking car?
That's just,
that's why I,
you know,
you don't,
you ever go like when they have open houses,
okay.
In,
you know,
in a nice neighborhood and you'd fucking you with,
whoever the fuck,
hey,
let's go look,
let's just fuck it.
And it's the worst thing you could ever fucking do,
you know,
because then he got to go back to where you live
and that's,
I'm warning you right now that you're going to watch this video and just know
that you're then going to have to go back to the car that you drive it and um,
whatever.
I love my Prius.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But Jesus Christ,
is that a fucking unbelievable car?
God Damn it.
You mother fuckers,
you should have to be making a certain amount of fucking money before you,
they even let you watch that video,
you know?
Fuck.
All right.
Anyways,
let's,
uh,
let's continue on here with the podcast.
Um,
all right.
This was an interesting email because this could go like 9,000 different ways.
All right.
See,
it says black guy voice.
It says bill,
my girlfriend and I have found a hot button issue between the two of us.
She hates a black guy voice that I do when I make jokes.
He goes,
I'm not black and neither is she.
Uh,
when we started dating,
I didn't really do it,
but when we were playing monopoly with one of my oldest friends and I started
winning once know once I was winning and my oldest friend was there,
the old black guy voice made an appearance.
I don't really say racist things.
What does that mean?
I don't really say racist thing.
Or He's saying like,
I can't tell cause you're writing this stuff.
So he goes,
I would just say stuff like,
Oh yeah,
give me that dollar or this is some Cheddar right here.
I'm not going to try to even do a fucking black guy voice here.
Oh,
hi.
Jackie went,
ah,
he goes,
I also show showered my dog and $500 bills and rubbed it all over his body.
Like I was,
uh,
at,
like it was a party.
My friend found it hilarious.
My girlfriend said I was mocking her.
I love that she's making it about her.
I thought that she was going like,
listen,
what you're doing is funny if you're doing it like if your heart's in the right
place,
but she's,
this is all about her.
She goes,
he goes,
personally,
I think she's,
I think being an asshole is an expected part of the game.
I guess the game of monopoly,
but that's just me.
He goes,
now that we've moved in together,
I continued to do the voice in a playful way.
Uh,
if she asked for a favor,
I might reply,
shirt dog.
I got you.
See,
I think that's fucking funny.
Um,
it goes,
and then she glares at me and tells me she hates that voice.
She doesn't understand.
This is when it gets weird though.
He goes,
oh,
then I'm making fun of people who talk like that and I'm not trying to make fun
of her.
This is where it goes off the raised rails for me.
Uh,
and I don't know,
but I don't know how you make it fun of him.
He just being ridiculous.
Like the way I'll do like a southern voice lack.
May it got,
damn it.
Get your fucking ass in here.
I asked for a sandwich.
Right.
And is that,
what is the rule?
Because I'm making fun of redneck white people and I'm white.
I'm allowed to do that.
Um,
it all depends on it real.
All of this shit.
It all depends on how you're doing it.
Like what your point is.
MMM.
Anyway,
so he goes,
I don't,
I don't really know was
well,
he goes,
I don't really know what she thinks I'm,
I'm doing.
Honestly,
I don't see what,
yeah,
it's so offensive about the voice.
Then he writes an,
I mean,
I like saying,
Ah Shit and mother fucker.
I like referring to our middle aged white neighbor as that ghetto ass n word.
I think it's funny now,
I gotta be honest with you.
Even that is funny.
If you just fucking around with white guy calling some middle aged white dude,
especially if he looks like Flanders.
Okay.
I Dunno.
And I know you're not supposed to say that,
but Urania house you fucking around.
It's your world.
It's your TV station.
And I really think if you,
if you're,
if you're not doing any of this maliciously,
like that's,
that's funny.
I think it's funny anyways,
but I don't know where you're coming from with this sir.
Anyways,
he goes,
my question is,
do you think I should stop doing the voice or do I have the right to continue
doing it?
You obviously have a right to continue doing it.
Um,
he goes,
I don't consider it racist and it's really just for laughs as a comedian,
I think you can appreciate that.
Is My girlfriend being too touchy about it and even if she is being to touch
you,
do I really have a say in it?
Is this the end of the black guy voice as we know it?
I don't even know what that means.
Sometimes I insist on her adding the word DJ before my name when she speaks to
me.
See,
dude,
I think you're just being silly,
but I just do that because I know it pisses her off.
And it's funny.
I'm not really an asshole bill.
I,
uh,
if you think I should stop,
I actually will.
It's time for a third party way on this.
Well,
the fact that you say,
if I actually said stop,
you will.
I think I,
it all depends on how you mean this,
but this actually
relates to stand up comedy right now where,
uh,
you know,
there's a lot of this people go out and they see your act,
they see a bunch of comedians and they listened to you tell a bunch of jokes and
then they pick out one joke,
okay.
And they define you,
they define you by that joke,
by how they heard the joke and they define your entire career by that
performance.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I had some blogger go off on me.
Um,
okay.
How about a show I did recently and it's like I just taped,
I just taped an hour and a half special.
I just burned an hour and a half of material.
I wasn't ready to go back out on the road.
I had the fucking Goddamn Mississippi River go through the lower part of my
fucking house and I have to make money or else I'm going to go wander.
Right.
Basically,
you know,
I'm going to get myself in a ridiculous amount of fucking debt.
So I went out before I was ready to go out and I am,
I need material.
And I,
you know,
one of these shows that somebody complained about was,
it was a city that I went to a year ago and I'm not going out there repeating
material.
I'm not fucking people over.
So I went out there and I did my thing.
And you know,
my act,
where my act is right now,
I don't like where my act is right now.
Yeah.
At all.
No comic does.
Two months after they take a special,
nobody is happy where they're fucking act as if you're really,
you know,
being honest with yourself.
So this person saw me and you know,
didn't like what I was talking about it absolutely.
You know,
I mean,
I just skim them,
send me,
sent me a link.
I just skimmed it.
I didn't really fucking read it,
but it was just like,
you know,
I wouldn't argue with a lot of your perception of it,
but to define me as a stand up comic on one fucking show.
Okay.
You know what I'm trying to try?
It's like doing stand up comedy.
It's not like playing guitar.
I can't sit in my bedroom and get better at it and when it's ready to be heard,
go out and go play.
I have to fucking go out there and just,
it's like fucking cooking pasta.
Remember the old days you took a noodle out,
you throw it at the wall and if it stuck it was done.
If it wasn't you kept going,
that's what you're doing.
So this fucking didn't like what I was talking about.
Absolutely trashed me and then like lied like completely either lied or was so
wrapped up in how much they didn't like what I was talking about that they
didn't see what happened.
I mean,
the show I did,
I got a partial standing ovation and they called me back out and this person
left all of that out,
left all of that shit out.
And it was just the way he was a monster.
He was hiring Barack Obama,
got in.
You know,
it's just one of those things where if you're joking,
if you're fucking joking,
then like I don't think the other person,
they know they can take it however they want to take it.
But just because they decide to take it seriously doesn't mean that you now
meant it and that sort of like a a,
that's kind of something that's going on.
So what I would say as far as what you're doing is,
you know,
if you're not a racist guy,
if you don't have issues and you're just doing it because it's a funny character
and I get doing a character that drives your wife up the wall,
I actually,
the character you do,
I will say,
I mean I don't drop the n word,
but I will say that I will do that type of slang.
But what I do is I,
I do it in my voice and I say it really seriously cause it,
it sounds absolutely grading to my wife and it either really makes her laugh or
annoys the shit out of her.
So,
um,
I dunno.
I think that's part of being with somebody.
You have to have something that you do that they find annoying and you find
hilarious,
so.
MMM.
You know,
I dunno.
It all,
it all depends.
I think it's funny that I would actually,
I can't even get,
give her shit that she,
she's making it about herself.
That actually is kind of one for your side that the way you're doing it isn't in
a racist way,
but she just doesn't like it.
I don't know.
Do the last thing you want to do is take any sort of advice from me when it
comes to fucking women because the way that I grew up was basically if somebody
didn't like something,
you did it even more.
MMM.
It was that sort of sadistic mean level of teasing and a,
for the longest time in my adult life I didn't know where the line was.
Um,
I used to have this,
this running joke where when I was living with Robert Kelly way back in the day,
he had a similar sadistic upbringing that was even worse than mine and he was
the only guy that I met that I can really think of that was further down that
road that I was in.
Basically when people would sit around,
like when we were even at the cellar.
Okay.
When the trashing would start,
a lot of times we would pick up
where the game ended would be our startup.
Nah,
maybe not at the cellar because it got pretty fucking me.
But generally speaking,
we would like where we started was the area that most people didn't even delve
in in that game.
And that became like the running joke for a while where people would tease the
two of us at how we played that game,
where someone would make fun of our shirt and then we'd be like,
yeah,
at least my mom is a dead,
like we would take it to and we wouldn't go that far,
but it was,
they would make,
so I actually had to learn
to dial it back,
um,
when it comes to stuff like that.
So,
uh,
like I said,
I wouldn't listen to me because I am fucking damaged goods.
Um,
alright.
Ghost writer.
Oh,
by the way,
I got to,
uh,
I got,
okay.
You know,
I gotta stop,
you know,
say obviously,
um,
the passing of Joan Rivers,
I know I talked about this last week,
but seriously,
without a doubt,
not even up for debate.
She's in the top five all time.
And I would actually,
okay,
if it was in Vegas and you,
he knew I had to bet who had written more standup material,
Joan Rivers or George Carlin.
Um,
I like,
I don't know what the spread would be on that because I saw her when she did
Fallon.
Right.
It was just really cool moment where,
you know,
okay,
she was in with Johnny Carson and then,
you know,
they offered her own talk shows a famous fucking story.
If you lived under a rock,
maybe you never heard it.
But,
and she agreed to do the talk show and she didn't get Johnny's blessing.
And uh,
he looked at it like,
hey,
I'm running a hardware store.
I'm letting you work here.
Right?
And then you open a hardware store across the street,
go fuck yourself.
You're dead to me.
And he never talked to her again.
Uh,
which I can understand being pissed off,
but never talking to her again.
I mean,
after he had like a 20 year fucking friendship is kind of weird.
Uh,
but if you read some of the autobiographies about his mom and what the fuck she
did to him and all kind of make sense.
So anyways,
she had not been on the tonight show since Johnny had,
if for whatever reason when Leno had it,
it never worked out where she got on the show.
I don't think Jay had anything against it.
She just never did the show.
So Fallon gets it and he brings her in and this is the first time she'd been on
the tonight show
in like 20 or 25 years.
And Jimmy took out a photo of her where she's on the tonight show with Johnny
Carson is Johnny Carson with like,
you know,
black or brown hair and not,
not even,
well one gray or white hair on top of his head.
And uh,
she saw it.
She goes,
oh my God.
that's my second appearance on the tonight show.
That was 1965.
So she basically,
she did panel talk show panel for almost half a century.
I mean,
you're talking about,
uh,
I dunno am the in the the Mount Rushmore comedy.
I think you got to put her in there.
You have to.
MMM.
So anyways,
yeah,
it's just,
I remember when I saw the documentary of her and she had though that fucking
card catalog of,
of like literally a library card catalog with all these jokes,
all these different topics and to be able to,
to last and be relevant.
That was another thing too,
is she never got like,
you know,
you'll see legendary comics who just,
they don't change with the times in their crowd.
They keep getting older and their crowd keeps getting older.
And I think what really
mmm
is a benchmark for you as an artist is if despite the fact that you keep getting
old,
um,
you keep you,
it's like every new generation,
it's like you're surfing and you catch that wave every fucking time.
And if you went to go see,
or you would see people from their 20s all the way up to her age,
you see that with acts like Neil Young.
There's very few,
um,
artists that do that.
And the only ones who do it are the ones that continue to,
I feel,
continued to grow.
MMM.
And they stay current or you just continue doing what you do and you,
what,
what you do.
You do.
It's so fucking well that it remains undeniable.
And to me that's ACDC and they're fucking hilarious about their body of work.
I remember one time somebody was,
gave him a little bit of a dig in an interview going like,
you know,
you've made the same al album
17 times in a row.
And then one of them in the band was like,
you know what,
that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
We've done it 18 times in a row.
And they all,
and everybody in the band laughed and
yeah,
no,
I mean I that might even be harder than fucking staying relevant is to do the
same sort of thing that long in a rough,
but anyway,
so a huge,
huge,
huge fucking huge loss.
Um,
without a doubt.
The real deal.
So Definitely gonna Ms. Joan Rivers.
So anyways,
with that,
because this is a comedy writing thing here,
somebody brought this up,
ghost writer.
Hello Bill.
Sorry,
I don't have any funny nickname to give you.
He said,
I wanted to get your take on ghost writers for Comedians.
Would you fault any comedian who has a ghost writer and or are ghostwriters a
commonly known part of standup comedy,
especially for Comedians that are well known slash established.
Thanks.
And don't go fuck yourself.
I like this guy.
He went,
he took a left turn,
no nickname,
and he didn't tell me to go fuck myself.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
what I fault.
Any comedian who has a ghost writer,
uh,
yeah,
I don't look at them the same as a comic who actually wrote all of their own
material.
Absolutely.
Um,
there's people who write their own material and then they get a TV or a movie
career and they want to keep going out on the road.
Um,
you know,
they don't have time to build up an act.
The smart thing to do is to go out and get a fucking writing staff.
And if that works for you,
that works for you personally.
Um,
I don't look at you the same way anymore because to me,
a comedian,
okay.
A pure comedian is writing all their own jokes and um,
You know?
Yeah,
there's people who do that and they have people that follow them around and they
sit in the back and they write down things that they say and uh,
you know,
it goes all the way from a,
the comedy version of getting,
you know,
getting a little booster chair at the table all the way to the Karen,
you off the field like fucking Kellen Winslow,
you know,
it's one of those deals.
So I think it all depends on the level that you do it.
Um,
I mean I'm also speaking out of school here cause I've never done that.
So I don't know how much of the hour ends up being what somebody else wrote that
you then add your own spin on.
But uh,
you know,
I don't think I'm unique in that.
I,
that takes a little,
uh,
a little shine off the apple for me.
Why,
whatever the fucking expression is.
If I find out the person actually have writers,
cause then I'm sitting there going,
well how much is this your thought?
Or is this somebody else's thought and then that you paid for?
So yeah,
no,
but people definitely have them.
And having said all that,
I don't necessarily think it's a bad thing to do.
It's a smart thing to do because uh,
nowadays with the Internet,
how everything gets made and then nobody pays for it.
I mean going out on the road,
tap dancing for your fucking lunch.
I mean you got to have an act,
right?
All right advice a dear Billy Bob Burg.
Uh,
need some girl advice.
I recently struck up conversation with a very attractive young lady
on the train the other day we talked for practically the whole 45 minute train
ride.
I'm 28,
but she was only 20.
Despite the age difference.
She was very cool.
And we talked about stand up comedy and how we are both fans of you.
All right,
so what are we talking about here?
This is weird.
We all send,
you brought me into it.
Get Gag.
You get me out of there.
Well,
when my stop arrived,
I left without asking for her number because I didn't want to be that guy.
What guy?
The Guy who finds love,
the guy gets laid
either way.
You're that guy.
You were that guy.
You were that guy that didn't ask for a number.
So he goes,
now I'm regretting it.
She told me where she works.
Okay.
A retail and I want to go there and ask her out.
So do you think it will come across creepy or sweet?
If I just showed up for work on announced she might not even be working at the
time,
but I could leave my number with the coworker.
Do not do that.
Any advice?
Love the podcast.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Uh,
I,
you know,
it's not creepy at all.
Okay.
You come in here with a raincoat.
You don't want to make eye contact.
Yeah,
go ahead.
that's going to be creepy.
We've come walking in and just be like,
listen,
it's been,
it's been bugging me.
I don't know if you remember me,
I met you on the bus,
blah,
blah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whatever needs to do.
Listen,
it's been bugging me from the second I got off the bus that I didn't ask you for
your number.
I wanted to ask you for your number,
but I didn't want to come off like a creep.
Uh,
you know,
I'd love to take you out sometime.
Just very simple,
very honest.
All right?
Don't be all fidgety and awkward,
you know,
just fucking go in there and just state your case.
All right.
Now she's not working there.
Don't stand outside the place.
You know,
fogging up the fucking windows waiting for to show up.
Just come walking in and just say is so and so here.
No.
Well,
when did she work again?
Blah,
blah,
you know?
All right.
Oh,
cool.
All right,
thank you.
Whatever.
Who can I say?
He's asking God the creepy guy from the bus.
MMM.
Whatever.
Yeah,
I would just go about it that way,
but absolutely do that and that whole fucking thing.
Hey,
I don't want to be that guy.
Be that guy.
Be The guy that asks for what he wants.
Be respectful of other people,
but you gotta be the guy.
All right,
boy,
you got to be the lady.
Either way,
you gotta beat that fucking thought out of your head.
You can be so respectful and so like not wanting to rock the boat that you never
even fucking,
you know,
get what you want in life.
All right?
Because life doesn't give a shit whether your dreams come true or not.
All right.
And a lot of the dreams that you have,
this isn't one of them,
but a lot of the dreams that you have,
like I always find it funny that people pray to a higher power,
oh please let me get this job.
Please let me Bababababa and all that type of shit.
The way this whole fucking world was set up,
if one person made it is if basically if you've got a roof over your head and
you're eating every day and you have drinking water,
your dream is fulfilled.
So to sit there and ask for a corner office of this person,
you're really just clogging up their phone lines.
Is that nuts?
I don't know.
That's how I look at it.
All right.
All in,
dear Billy,
brain fart.
Back in December,
2012 I was enlisted in the United States air force.
Off,
we go into the wild blue yonder
flying into this guy and we dive in.
That's all I know because that's all they play in the movies,
right?
Better
let's just a credit,
eh,
Eh,
eh.
Okay.
You gotta do
nothing can stop us.
Air Force.
How would a stronger air force,
yeah,
I'll tell you right now.
They wanted to cheer up your chip.
They feel like they're unstoppable and that's the kind of thing that ends up
getting you shot down out of the sky.
You have to feel the weak side pressure of the third world countries.
I mean,
planes are disappearing.
Who's to say that these people don't have these things?
All right.
Um,
despite being engaged,
oh wait a second.
I got engaged.
Oh yeah.
The guy joins the fucking air force.
All right.
He enlisted.
I got engaged to what I thought was the lady of my dreams.
Life was good.
Unfortunately,
I got stationed out of state and had to move despite being engaged.
She opted to stay behind and what was supposed to be temporary.
We managed to keep the spark alive for some time until she lost.
Yeah.
The engagement ring in April,
2013 all right,
let's stop right there.
Guys are morons and a man can lose a fucking ring.
All right?
The only way a woman could lose a ring is if she's cleaning it near a sink.
Okay.
And she doesn't understand plumbing.
And then later turns on the water and sends it through the j trap.
All right.
These kind of feel the weak side pressure on the j trap on fourth down
situations.
Um,
what a woman loses a rating.
You gotta understand like this,
that's so many of them.
That's the thing.
The ring,
they get the fucking sticking out of their fucking girlfriends noses.
Yeah.
Bed.
Yay.
Right?
They live for that.
That's like you getting a game worn jersey.
All right.
So she lost a fucking engagement ring.
Wow.
Eventually things spiraled out of control and she left me in June of 2013 saying
I deserved better.
All right.
Well that means either she doesn't love herself and uh,
like when I sing that you deserve better.
What I would immediately think is such,
if a woman ever said that to me that it's like,
all right,
you fucked around on me and how many times?
Uh,
anyways,
this put me in a huge state of depression to which I credit your podcast for
helping me out.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Um,
come to find out she back.
Oh,
she banked for different guys from June to August.
There you go.
And those are just the ones she admitted to.
Okay.
That's like when you come home,
buzzed or drunk in high school and your parents go,
how many bears are your head?
How many,
what do you say to you're really shit face.
You'll save four.
And she said for,
so what does that mean?
She had a 12 pack.
A Dick?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
In August she came back into my life after she said she went,
she too went through a depressant.
She was living even further away now,
but still wanted to try and make things work some type of way.
Finally,
February of this year,
I got the chance we were waiting on,
I went house hunting.
Ooh,
Jesus.
Dude,
what are you doing?
Where she lived in a to in attempt to make things right.
Come to find out she had been banging a married guy with kids and also talking
to someone else,
telling me,
wait and also talking to someone else while telling me she wanted me.
I confronted her and she basically said,
all I'll ever be to her is a fucking facetime friend.
What you confronted her and she said all and she said,
A week ago she called me and now she wants to be friends again.
I love this girl.
That is your problem sir.
That is the only reason why you're writing me because everything you're saying,
this is a joke,
your decision.
He goes,
I love this girl very much despite what she's done to me.
Kind of like eating sugar.
It's good,
but it fucks you in the long run.
My question to you is,
do I throw all my chips in this time or do I fold and yes,
I'm probably an idiot either way.
Thanks for the laughs and go fuck yourself.
Ps do a show and Mississippi already.
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
that's on my bucket list.
I'm going to do one down there.
Um,
all right,
here's the deal,
dude.
This is the deal.
Your heart is clouding your brain right now.
All right?
And uh,
here's a great expression that somebody said that their therapist told them one
time.
They said,
I don't let chaos live in my life.
All right,
this is the deal.
Okay.
Um,
she has come from some sort of unhealthy fucking background where she feels that
yeah,
she's got some sort of low self esteem thing.
I'm guessing she just thinks that she's a piece of shit and probably doesn't
deserve a great guy like you.
So she deliberately went out and sabotaged it probably because she's used to
being around a bunch of dysfunctional fucking people.
So when she actually found somebody outside of our wheelhouse,
she ran back to the see the comfort of that dysfunctional horse shit.
All right.
That is not your fucking problem.
Okay.
When you're trying to find the person that you supposed to fucking be with,
you have to find somebody that is his right as rain.
All right?
That's why you asked the questions.
Are Your parents still together?
What are your relationship like?
All the red flags,
both for men and women listening to this thing.
Okay.
If they have issues with their fucking parents and they don't fucking speak to
them and they have a lot of anger issues towards their family,
fucking walk.
Walk.
All right.
If you're young,
you're drafted in the first round,
okay?
Okay.
That's the Dez Bryant pic,
like fucking bill Belicheck.
He passed on that one and everyone's like,
dude,
what are you talking about?
That's a fucking 10 and look at them.
Not saying the dude isn't a 10 not saying he's not a worldclass fucking athlete,
but all the,
the baggage that comes with that horse shit.
You got to look at it like that.
So well you need to do is,
you know,
all right,
you want to compare it to sugar.
You want to get over your sugar addiction.
Just go cold Turkey.
All right?
Six days fucking in.
Yeah.
Okay.
You're going to start to turn and you're going to be looking at candy and cake
and pies going,
why the fuck would I ever eat that?
Because it's out of your system and that's how you're going to look at her.
Why the fuck would I ever eat that?
Yeah.
Do,
that's not the mother your kids man,
you know?
Yeah.
That right there is a Hank Williams song waiting to be written.
If you marry her and you have kids with her.
All right?
Yeah.
I mean dude,
that,
that's the kind of woman that could turn you into a fucking alcoholic.
Uh,
you need to walk away.
Okay.
All right.
And you know what?
You live in Mississippi,
so you understood that fucking Hank Williams reference.
All right.
Walk away and uh,
and stay single for a while until you get that craving outta you.
Cause it's not fair for you to get into another relationship with that shit
there and you probably want to build,
how do you know all this shit?
Because I'm a fucking piece of shit and I've done it.
I've been like,
all of these,
all of these questions,
I've been both people.
I've been the person that fucked around.
I'd been the person that got fucked around on,
I made horrible fucking decisions in all of that shit.
And it was,
it wasn't until I finally fucking decided to a,
you know,
stop surrounding myself with fucking people that reminded me of people that I
grew up with.
Okay.
And actually tried to create,
oh,
where did a culture in the locker room.
Um,
so that's what you need to do.
Yeah.
You need to,
uh,
you need to draft character first.
All right?
There's plenty of beautiful women that came from wonderful families and those
Dell,
that's the one that's the keeper.
All right?
I know what the Shit,
okay.
A woman like this is fucking your brains out.
I know she is.
Okay.
And that's the sugar right there.
So you got to let that go.
All right,
here's the deal.
Next time you,
you're thinking about calling her rub one out.
I'm dead serious.
Fucking rub one out.
And the second you'd done,
I bet as your orgasm,
you're gonna this,
you're gonna be like,
ah,
thank God I didn't call her.
That's what's going to happen.
All right.
And remember that thought.
Single for a week.
Dear Billy,
buzz balls and the lovely knee,
if she's available,
she isn't,
unfortunately.
He goes,
I am 22 years old dating a 19 year old girl who goes to school an hour away.
All right?
Uh,
we had been dating since her year and we've been able to maintain a very loving
relationship while maintaining our own independent lives outside of it.
Jesus.
What could go wrong?
Um,
before I decided to get serious with her,
I bow to remind myself that there may be a point where I have to let her go.
Considering the drastic changes that go on at Miss,
uh,
miss the college years.
If it works out with her,
I will be immensely happy.
But if she needs time to grow that I love her enough to be content with giving
her that time.
You said you're talking like you're her first serious relationship.
Recently she expressed a curiosity.
What would be like if she wasn't in a relationship in college?
And my mind immediately went to something that you said on a recent podcast
about the influential Dick's that girls need to suck in college.
I said that,
um,
I don't think I said that.
Did I say that anyways?
Although you'd be a shit poet.
I knew you were.
Well,
I knew what you were getting at.
So we decided that we'd take a week off and drop the maintenance of a long
distance.
One our relationships so she could experience for single self and college.
We said no hooking up and she expressed that her intentions were not to get with
other dudes and I do actually believe her,
but you never know.
It was more about handling adversity at school without me and to uh,
and to overall take a break from the long distance responsibilities.
Like I said,
although it's hard,
I did emotionally prepare myself knowing that she may eventually change your
mind and need space.
I like Nias and your opinion on the idea of,
uh,
of the week break and overall situation.
Love the podcast and you fucking crushed it at the Chicago odd ball show and it
was a privilege to see your,
your act,
uh,
thanks again and go fuck yourself.
Well,
it's funny.
That's the fucking show I got shit about.
Um,
anyways.
Oh,
and by the way,
if you find that blogger,
do not write a bunch of negative shit like fuck you,
you fucking content.
Because all that does is just feed into what they're writing.
Okay.
If you want to look at it,
look at it.
But please,
because if I was to meet that person,
I would not talk to that person that way.
I wouldn't,
I would listen to what they were saying.
I would state my case and that would be it.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Um,
I don't think a week as long enough,
a long enough time.
The problem is when you get into a relationship,
this series at that young of age,
you know,
if you've been dating a year,
you met her when she was 18.
You met her as a freshman.
So she went from the first 18 years of her life of,
you know,
being in the nest with her parents.
She's finally out on her own,
and then she immediately gets into a relationship.
She doesn't know who she is,
you know what I mean?
Um,
so,
and I don't think you can do that in a week.
Okay.
I don't,
you know,
some people can do it,
only need a couple now.
Some people,
you know,
meet people in college and then they married their college sweetheart and that's
it.
They're fine with it and all that.
And other people,
you know.
Okay.
Need to fucking make a bunch of mistakes through their twenties,
thirties and into their forties
all the pens.
So,
um,
I think you guys are going to have to figure this out,
but uh,
there is,
you know,
that's an amazing time in your life when you move out and it's all of a sudden
like,
hey,
I can stay up as late as I want to.
Hey,
I can eat whatever I want to.
I can drink as much as I want to drink.
And then you have to learn how to be a parent to yourself to say,
hey,
fuck had it's time to go to bed.
Don't take this.
Like,
Hey,
you're driving,
don't drink and drive a dude.
You don't have a condom.
Or if you're a woman,
he doesn't have a condom.
No.
Walk away.
Like learning how to walk away is,
uh,
you know,
in those dumb situations can I mean that those are life altering fucking moments
because horrible,
horrible fucking things can happen.
Uh,
in those moments in you need to,
I,
I'm not speaking for myself.
I feel like you need to learn those things and I don't think you can do that in
a week.
So,
uh,
I,
I would just have a serious conversation with her about that,
you know?
And it's hard for me to really give you a tell you exactly what to do because,
um,
my whole life experience is super imposed and informing everything that I'm
saying.
So I'm not you guys,
I didn't have your guys' upbringing.
There's a lot of people that marry their college sweethearts and they live
happily ever fucking after.
And,
uh,
and they don't have to go through all the fucking drama that I went through.
Um,
so I think you guys need to have a conversation about it and honest conversation
and uh,
see where the chips fall and then fucking act on it.
Um,
that's it.
Good Luck and God bless America.
Um,
anyways,
that is the uh,
oh fuck.
Did I even read the other?
I get to read the other advertising here and then maybe till another quick story
I just saying that I have another quick story to tell you.
So you'll actually listen to this fucking advertising so I won't get shit.
Who knows these another interesting questions answered next week on the Monday
morning podcast stamps.com everybody computers are designed to make running a
business easier,
including your mailing and shipping.
Just use stamps.com to get 24 hour access to the post office right from your own
computer.
No waiting in line,
no hassles,
man stamps.com makes mailing and shipping easy.
Just use the computer and printer.
You already have to get official US postage for any letter,
any package print.
The post is directly onto envelopes,
labels,
um,
even plain paper,
then hand it to your mail carrier.
There's no guesswork.
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the
exact postage you need for any class of male.
You'll never ever have to go to the post office again.
Personally,
I use stamps.com,
uh,
to send out all my posters that I sell up to some of my shows.
I'm a moron.
If I can figure out how to use that scale and calculate the right price,
then God dammit.
So can you right now he's my last name.
Burpee.
You rr for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
Um,
don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburbburthatstamps.com enter
burp.
All right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
When you're planning your for your future,
uh,
you do financial planning,
you get insurance.
Uh,
but to get real peace of mind.
You know,
it's funny,
I thought piece of mine was spelled incorrectly piece because of iron maiden
peace of mind and I forgot that that was a,
that they spelled it the other way anyways,
but to get real peace of mind,
you got to make sure your family and finances are legally protected.
So where do you turn for legal help that you can trust?
Only one place.
Place Legal zoom.com for over 13 years they've been helping Americans get
personalized wills,
powers of attorneys and living trusts.
Legal Zoom also helps file ll sees s corporations and more to protect your you
against personal liability.
Sorry,
I forgot to make this bigger so I can see it.
All right.
The company has started,
was started by some of the best legal minds in the country and they make it
painless for you to get the legal protection you need.
Have questions.
You can always reach out to someone at legal zoom and they'll talk you through
the whole process anyways.
You can get the legal help through independent attorneys and self help services
at your own discretion,
but they are not a law firm for special savings.
Be sure to enter my code burpee you are and the referral Bach in the referral
box at checkout.
Go to legalzoom.com/bur bur to today to protect your business and take control
of your family's future.
All right everybody,
that is the Monday morning podcast for this week.
Hey,
let's,
let's see.
You want to hear something funny cause I don't know shit about football anymore.
Not like I ever did.
Let's actually look at some of,
uh,
let's go to nfl.com right now and let's look at week two and I'm going to make
some predictions.
And this is the thing,
I have no idea who won what,
although I will tell you,
uh,
Seattle look fucking unbelievable and I love that filthy Pete Carroll got busted
for whatever the fuck he was doing.
I thought he got busted him.
He just got busted for that.
He was having them practice like with pads on or full contact before he should
have.
Dude,
that guy,
you look,
I,
I've never been more wrong about somebody.
Then Pete Carroll maybe drew Bledsoe when we chose Tom Brady over drew Bledsoe
after we won our first one and we traded him to the buffalo bills.
I was like,
that guy's going to come back to haunt us.
I was wrong.
It never happened.
And Pete Carroll,
I was one of those going,
you know,
even after he was doing well at USC,
I was like,
dude,
you know,
we get heat.
Oh,
he's not a pro coach.
You know,
and I can say that having never coached a fucking pro and a fucking pop Warner
game,
uh,
that guy is psychotically driven and,
and I,
I,
you know,
those guys could win it again if he's going to fucking be that much of a maniac.
Did,
like he,
he making that move to me says three days after the Superbowl,
his wife was in the other room crying,
going,
are you ever going to be happy?
Right.
He was already glazing over with x's and o's in front of his fucking ice.
Um,
I think it's great,
that level of commitment,
although I have to say the championship ring that they made for their own fans.
I mean it's just,
I can't,
the Deuce chills when you look at that.
Oh my God,
the fucking ball washing and everybody is bought into how fucking loud they are.
You could take Jackson,
Jill Jackson,
Phil Jack and Jill Jackson,
Jacksonville Jaguar fans,
put them in Seattle Stadium and they would be just as loud.
I challenge every NFL fan to go to a game there,
stand in that crowd,
listen to how loud it is,
and then turn around and look at people cheering.
Just look at them.
Then add up.
They're like,
like fuck of these crazy.
They just cheering
what they own or did was brilliant because it wasn't illegal.
And I think that every other owner is going to do it around the NFL unless they
do something about that stadium,
which,
what are you going to do about it?
It's already fucking built.
Um,
that he just was brilliant.
He's like,
contain this fucking noise in,
reign it back down on the field.
You know,
I'm not saying they're not great fans,
but Jesus Christ,
could you pat yourselves on the back anymore?
Oh,
I know.
And I keep doing this and I get total respect for Pete Carroll and your football
program up there.
Obviously a program,
a franchise up there.
I think you guys,
I mean,
I dunno,
it's obviously the little football that I watched.
It seems once again that uh,
it's a no brainer that the
okay.
The super bowl champion at once again,
it's coming out of the NFC and uh,
Tehran.
Yo La.
I'm a football fan.
I got to be looking into that first batch up.
Oh,
the Seattle Seahawks against those San Francisco 40 niners Kenya 40 niners get
over the hump.
I mean this is the question.
I mean there's rumors that Jim Harbaugh is losing the locker room.
Okay.
How can you sit and watch that?
Um,
anyways.
all right,
let's get to,
let's get to the week two to schedule for next week.
Let's see if he can find
what the fuck schedules.
All right.
Standing stats with the fuck is week to matchups.
Ah,
you know what I,
these is,
you know,
can you make it easy for a fucking old guy?
Scouting,
combine,
draft play off play off
team's schedule.
Oh,
regular season schedule right there.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
Week two.
What Buddha,
Buddha did the due to all the giants played alliance tonight in Detroit.
I have no idea who's going to win that.
I don't understand why everybody's questioning Eli Manning.
How many fucking Superbowls does a guy get a when all of a sudden he doesn't
know how to play the position anymore?
Fucking New York media.
That's the problem.
When you get 15 papers all in one town,
they always gotta be constantly stirring up shit.
Not that they don't do it in Boston.
Believe me.
I know they do.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Yeah,
this is all week one stuff.
Where's week tow?
The fuck is it?
I don't know,
Bill,
why don't you just yell at your computer,
Texas sized triumph.
This is,
this is why.
This is why I need a fucking assist.
I gotta do something here because this should not be this difficult.
September 4th through the ninth
okay.
Complete wheat one schedule.
Where the fuck is the week to schedule your cunts?
Can I scroll this way?
Yeah,
this is bad.
This is really,
this is awful.
No.
Is this it right here?
No,
that isn't it.
All right.
I'm not going to torture you guys anymore.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I can.
I know what you didn't want to hear my pics anyways.
You didn't wanna hear my pics anyways.
Don't tell you in new ways.
I can tell you follow it.
You know what?
I'll give you my predictions for week to week to pregame football analysis and
now often new England where a shark legally last week they lost the size of Lee.
So these Miami Dolphins of the dolphin,
Miami County,
Dane Wade,
fucking area cub,
I'll tell you right now,
I mean,
what do you think's going to happen when they come in and they play the a the
fucking the fucking Austin city.
I should topes what do you think's going to happen?
Well,
I'll tell you right now.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
You'll be,
look,
we all know with Tom Brady could do,
we all know bill Bella check is a genius,
but I'll tell you right now,
I mean,
I mean you did talent or no child and I mean you gotta be,
you gotta be concerned about that second half.
I mean,
south Southtech it's gotta be a lot of that shit.
if they lose today,
they're all went to the first time in the Brady bill checker
like I to be doing that for a fucking hour,
not for an hour.
They'll do it for a little bit and then they're gonna.
Uh,
I dunno what the fuck else they going to talk about.
I see the world through my,
and I know that they're
going to be doing that shit.
Or you can just skip all of that and you can go fucking work out at the gym,
right?
Go for a hike with your fucking dog or some shit and he can come back.
The wonderful world of fucking Dvi,
you can come back an hour before the game,
after the game started.
He ain't just plow through all the fucking halftime,
everything and just get right to the third corner,
right?
Let your wife watched the real housewives during the first half,
you know,
and you just make,
before you go out to the gym,
he just say,
listen sweetheart,
you grab by a handful of hair,
the back of her head fellowship.
If new [inaudible] shut off the recording.
I swear to God,
I'm going to have you live under the coffee table.
Not Joking.
I'm joking.
Blogger worlds.
Um,
anyways,
that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next week.
And my prediction tonight is giant is always get off to a slow start on a Tory
is slow start the DS,
Detroit lions of the fucking greater line area code.
If been gradually improving throughout the years.
But do this.
I have no idea.
For some reason I'm going to just,
you know what?
I bet against me.
I'm going to pick the lions.
All right,
there you go.
go fuck yourselves.
Oh,
and here's the phone.
Talk to you next week.